we're now on test number six and section
3 so let's just get started problem
number one which of the following
numbers is between one fifth and
one-fourth so when you look at the
choices you immediately see that all of
the numbers are decimals so let's just
convert these two decimals one-fifth is
one it's point two and one-fourth is
point two five so we need a number
that's larger so let me call it X so
it's going to be larger than point2 and
less than point two five and if you look
at the choices d is that answer and if
you didn't know offhand that one-fifth
is point2 you could divide five and two
one point oh five goes into 10 2 times 2
times 10 is 10 0 and then of course the
decimal you bring up so it's point 2
times and just do the same thing with
one-fourth next problem problem to the
following our coordinates of points in
the XY plane which of these points is
nearest the origin so if we look at a
all of the choices well we could let me
actually write all the choices down we
have a a says zero minus one half B is I
was thinking whether i should draw these
for you but it's good to learn how to do
this without drying it 0 1 half c is
one-half minus one-half d is one-half
one-half and e is minus one minus one so
if we look at all the choices you know
this is that we did move it all along
the x-axis here right because we're
still at x equals 0 we wanted to figure
out how far it is away from zero so we
didn't move at all from the x axis and
we went one below the y axis here 2-1
clearly this B is closer than a because
b is only one half away right once again
we didn't move on the x axis we only and
we've only moved one half away on the
y-axis so a is not our choice so far be
is our best content
it's only one half away from from the
origin c is one half away in the x
direction and one half away in the y
direction and if you do the math if you
use the Pythagorean theorem you'll see
that of course is going to be further
than one-half and let me just draw a
little bit of a graphic for you just so
you get the intuition how I can do that
without drawing it so this point is 0 1
half so it's 0 1 half let's call this
one half so that point is here that's
our best contender right now 0 1 half
the point one half negative one half is
here see this is one half minus one half
is here my minus one half so its
distance from the origin is this line
right here and that distance is
definitely going to be longer than this
distance how do I know because this
distance is just is the same thing as
this distance it's the same thing as one
half to the negative side right and if
you do the Pythagorean theorem and we
could figure it out this distance is one
half as well this is the square root of
this is going to be the square root of
what one one half squared plus one-half
squared so one-fourth plus one-fourth
which is one-half so it's a square root
of one-half which is one over the square
root of two which is the same thing as 2
square roots of 2 over 2 any way you
look at it it is a bigger number than
one-half and we when you take a square
root of a fraction you're going to get
something bigger than the fraction right
so this is essentially the square root
of one-half so it's going to be bigger
than one-half so stitt so we know that
this isn't the choice D is the same
distance as CD is up here it's just in
the positive quadrant right because
we're this distance is one-half and then
this distance is one-half saudi for the
same reason is is further than B and E e
is the farthest of them all right it's
one away in two directions so it's it's
out here someplace relative to this
origin so that's not the choice OB is
definitely the closest it's only
one-half units away from the origin next
problem
I will change colors for variety problem
3 problem 3 ok they drew a lot here let
me see if I can draw the same thing they
did so they have a horizontal line and
then let's see they have I want to draw
it just like the way they did it and
then so then there's how many then
there's 11 10 3 4 5 i'm telling you
drawing it is the hardest part so and
they have something like this like that
then like that and then the next two
don't go all the way through they go
kind of halfway and goes like that and
that one that's my best shot and then
they say that this is switched this is X
degrees X degrees X degrees X degrees X
degrees X degrees X degrees and then
they say that this big one right here is
why degrees and the figure above what is
the value of y well the first thing I
would do is figure out what the value of
x is and how do I do that well you could
say you know you could make a whole
circle or whatever but you could say
look all of these X's here these how
many is that 1 2 3 4 5 x's right these 5
x's are collectively supplementary to
each other right they're going to add up
to 180 degrees so we know that 5x is
equal to 180 degrees and that x is equal
to how many times does 5 go into 185
goes into 150 30 times and so there's
another 30 so we'll go into 36 x so x is
equal to 36 degrees and you just divide
180 by 5 to get that so how do we figure
out why well the easy way to do this and
say well if you go into the other side
of that if you go to the other side of
the circle if you go to this side of the
circle
that's also going to be equal to 180
degrees right so we have two x's here we
have two x's here and then we have Y
right so you could say why y plus 2x is
equal to 180 I know what X is X except
is 36 degrees so y plus 2 x 36 and 72 is
equal to 180 y is equal to what is that
y is equal to 180 minus 72 is 108
degrees now if you wanted to do this
really really really fast what you could
have said is well you know what if I
kept drawing these X's all the way
around the circle right so let's say
that you know add lines like I don't
like this let me say this line actually
just continues on like this let's say
that this line continued on like this
and we know that this would kind of in a
visualization exercise but you would
have known that this is X this is X this
is X and then how many X's total out
there one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten there would have been 10
x's right and we're going all the way
around the circle so 10 X would equal
360 X is equal to 36 and then a really
easy thing because I said well why is
three of these X's right one two three
why is three of those X's so three times
36 is equal to 108 either way would have
been fine I think the way we did the
first time what didn't take too long but
if you do it can do it faster that's
that's all the better at some point the
s80 really just becomes a speed exam
problem number 4 if 6565 is equal to 65
times X plus 1 then x equals so the real
trick is here is being able to divide
fast divide both sides by 65 you get 65
goes into 65 65 goes into 65 one time
one time 6500 6 because
zero time just going to zero 65 and 65
one time so you divide both sides by 65
you get 10 1 is equal to X plus 1
subtract 1 from both sides you get 100
is equal to X this is just kind of a
speed problem maybe they want to get you
make you have a careless mistake so the
answer C I'll see in the next video